in a previous video we talked about the
data lake house concept and shared a
story about how data lake houses are
much like the operations of a commercial
kitchen in a restaurant so definitely
check out that video If you haven't seen
it today I'd like to discuss more about
the key drivers for and values delivered
by an open data lake house architecture
as well as share a couple examples
and help me do that I'm very excited to
invite Edward calisburt director of
product management for IBM databases to
join us Edward thanks for being here hey
love
so Edward let's start with the major
macro trends that we're seeing and that
are leading organizations to modernize
their Analytics infrastructures
how has the use of data shifted
drastically in the past couple years
well of there are three major macro
trends that we're seeing in the market
first the amount and the cost of data is
exploding
second data consumption patterns are
expanding and changing
and third data architecture is being
disrupted and transformed
so could you speak briefly about each of
these
sure
so there's no doubt that the amount
of data is expanding rapidly
but also it's coming from a variety of
different sources
and in all sorts of new
data formats
what this means is that to manage all of
this data Enterprises are spending more
money and some estimate that that is in
the range of 30 percent year over year
okay so when you talk about the cost of
data are you just referring to the cost
of storing it in different repositories
like data Lakes warehouses or other
stores or are you also referring to the
cost of managing and governing the life
cycle of that data well it's actually
both
let's talk about the patterns of data
consumption
there's an ever increasing demand for
the use of data especially from business
users
there's no doubt that Analytics
has become an essential component of
almost every job and certainly
AI the use of AI is expanding rapidly
now this doesn't mean that every
business user needs to become an AI
expert but it does mean that more and
more we're seeing AI being used to
automate and optimize certain decisions
at scale such as advertising campaigns
or supply chain Networks
AI is also being used to augment human
in the loop decision making such as
credit risk underwriting
this means Enterprises are always
looking for more data
and use it to drive new insights
right and and you know what about the
data privacy and data regulatory
concerns that are around AI sure when
you combine this with increasing
regulatory standards Enterprises will
require higher levels of built-in data
security and governance in order to
enable this data sharing and consumption
absolutely and you know another thing
that we hear a lot is the
democratization of data so it's about
create it's about time to Value right
business users yes they need data but
they need it like yesterday right it
doesn't do the user or the organization
a lot of benefit if it takes long
complicated processes for users to get
access to that data so to get the most
value out of the data it's got to be
consumed as quickly as possible
and all while still adhering to those
governance and compliance policies would
you agree with that absolutely
that leads us to our third point which
is architecture
organizations are realizing that the way
the data is managed needs to change
the emergence of commodity Cloud object
storage
and the adoption of open data formats
is really allowing Enterprises to
increase the return on investment in
data management and they're doing this
through the optimization of the price
performance
of their workloads across different
storage and compute tiers now what does
that mean it means that organizations
can benefit from having the right tool
for the right job at the right cost
instead of defaulting into a data
warehouse which may be appropriate in
some cases but can also become very
expensive and ineffective in others
right so what I'm hearing is more data
more users and more uses of that data
right and all while still better ways to
share and manage access around it right
um so Edward
how are these aspects related to the key
values that are delivered by an open
data lake house architecture
great question love
we see three key values that are
delivered by an open data Lake as
architecture first
an open data lake house provides the
foundation for users to easily and cost
effectively access store manage and
unify large amounts of data and from
different sources and in different
formats
second an open data lake house
can be easy to deploy within existing
environments providing users fast access
to more data without having long
procurement onboarding or data
pipelining and wrangling processes
making it much easier to consume
and third open data lake houses can
optimize your analytics workloads to run
where they perform the best and are most
cost efficient
all this part of an integrated
architecture
wow so you know I've noticed one thing
you've said the word open a lot can you
explain to us what the difference is
there sure I'm glad you wrote that up
a lake house should leverage the
capabilities across existing data and
analytics environments if you already
have data and analytics workloads in a
data warehouse or in a Hadoop data Lake
that's okay you shouldn't be forced to
migrate or rip and replace that
environment in order to get started with
the lake house but what about new data
and new workloads well a lake house
should be the starting point for new
data and new workloads as well as
provide a modernization path for
existing environments over time you know
the other thing that we hear often is
customers getting stuck with one vendor
well also open also means that you're
always in control of your data and you
aren't forced into proprietary data
formats or specialized Tooling in order
to use it it also means that you can
maximize the use of your data without
having to make copies of it and move it
around and this provides for lower costs
higher productivity and better
governance which ultimately leads to
what Enterprises are looking for which
is more trusted decisions wow so Edward
what I'm hearing is
a data lake house
is like a network of highways
some of them
have tolls on them
and some of them don't like regular
freeways
and a lake house allows you to go on the
toll road pay when you need to get
somewhere really fast but when you're
not in a hurry and there's no traffic
take the regular Highway
love that's a great analogy think about
using a data lake house to cut your data
warehousing costs by up to half by
optimizing the price performance of your
analytic workloads or like you're saying
saving money by driving on the freeway
while there's no traffic and you're not
in a hurry wow Edward that sounds really
exciting let's hit the road let's do it
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below